[Applause]
listen we have no introduction for this
because it's happening right now in the
moment i had to get to the bottom of
this okay yeah you did
you had to get to the top of it too
andrew hey that's a freudian slip
done on purpose okay listen we gotta
mount this topic real quick guys
out this topic okay listen we got my man
you're robbie bro i know your real name
is tanner okay but to me you're robbie
from cobra kai robbie keane
okay okay sir okay listen
first of all how old are you i i am 21.
okay we just need to make sure we need
to make sure that because i was going
off
last episode
how what's up all right
anyway okay look he's all his feelings
are okay everything's fine now
everything's fine so this is something
that i needed to bring up because this
was serious okay
i had you were looking as akash said to
smoldering
on the podcast and it made me feel
uncomfortable son you've been smoldering
not the podcast on the show i can't even
speak i'm so nervous
okay so listen listen
listen listen i'm [ __ ] trembling
right now i'm so excited
i should have got a haircut so
in all seriousness in all seriousness
you were looking too cute as [ __ ] on the
show
okay and i tried to bring this up in a
very
safe space which i thought that this
podcast was and then they don't don't
touch your hair like that but don't
touch it don't do that
so so these guys tried to front like you
weren't
as pretty as you are
okay listen listen he they literally
tried to do it
you denied it objectively this kid is
pretty as [ __ ]
all right but you have feelings for the
kid and i'm just saying he looks like
mark okay that's where [ __ ] got
uncomfortable because i was just gonna
sexually harass you from a distance
right as we do nowadays right never
thinking that we were gonna have this
conversation but god bless
okay and then akash had to make it
personal by saying
mark and you look similar okay are you
personally offended by that
absolutely not i was
i was offended yeah because i have like
high
quality you know standards you know what
i mean
what what al does he know what mark
looks like okay so we're going to bring
on mark
so that you can see mark because i don't
think that you guys he might be offended
mark trying to look different than you
but y'all like the [ __ ]
taylor what'd you say ignore the braids
okay let's see the braids
oh yeah i got my brush okay oh yeah my
hair is crazy yeah you look amish bro
you look absolutely ridiculous you look
crazy right now
what happened to the top dude
what's going on with this guy dude
am i supposed to look at that and then
look at this yo he reminds you of the
mark you used to love
yeah mark get out of here a little house
on a prairie ass mark
orthodox ass carl living in williamsburg
too long
okay problem is though is is mark
completely white
oh are you not
tan not white tanner buchanan
okay so the thing is is you're so good
at telling people's ethnicities
okay because i i've watched you since
the new year since uh all the coveted
shit's been going on and like
i'm like super into you oh like oh [ __ ]
keep talking that [ __ ] with your 21 year
old legal ass
all the coven [ __ ] that's been going on
i got super into your videos
and it's just super great at telling who
uh what ethnicities people are
yeah um i don't think you can see past
your beauty dog i hate
well i hate to inform i'm not completely
white i know you're mexican bro you're
half mexican
you're i'm half mexican is that right
that's what you got
try again oh [ __ ] 75
no no no try again portuguese or some
white [ __ ] like that
i i i'm not i'm not latin at all you're
not laughing
you're laughing eating we try to guess
tell us you cute [ __ ] he's asian
oh you ruined it for me dawg
white boy i'm back mark you're back
let's go
let me undo those braids for you mark
cause i gave you a handle
i'm actually uh i'm a quarter filipino
oh that's not real asian why not come on
yo
no that's not really they're not even
asian asians that's fine that's spanish
asian
it's a new 1 8 mexican 1 8 chinese yeah
that's
did you know karate before or is that
just did that was that like some [ __ ]
you need to pick up girls
they're saying
if some [ __ ] goes down am i safe tanner
you let me get to the second part of my
question
my bad my bad my bad go you can answer
the question but don't say anything past
uh episode two of season two because i
haven't gone past that
it's okay you guys are still on that
wheel with the water trying to learn how
to do karate
and you got some lululemon spandex on
for some reason
sam was wearing something too i don't
remember but she was wearing something
oh [ __ ] um yo can you play that guitar
for us
the only song that i'm comfortable like
singing and playing is
creep by radiohead oh that is the
whitest [ __ ] you could have possibly
said on this podcast
fully describes how i've been
i can't play creep by radiohead if you
want yeah
yeah you want you want creep yeah all
right fine fine we'll do white people's
national anthem it is our national
anthem
sing to him like he's danny larusso
we're gonna sing ready just imagine i'm
sam
imagine i'm saying i got uh you want me
to start with the uh
chorus because that's yeah that's the
thing everybody knows let's do that one
you and i we're on the wheel together
it's all about balance yo one shot on
andrew please karate is about bounce
start at the end miyagi doe is all about
balance
okay i'll give you an intro all right
and then we'll
uh we'll go to the chorus okay good all
[Applause]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
you know this one taylor yeah andrew's
not gonna be able to stand up here
[Music]
i'm a creep oh god
[Music]
facts
[Music]
oh
[Music]
listen robby if you were so cute i would
have cut that [ __ ] off
okay yo robby man i'm over you buddy
robbie bro definitely a guitar player
i'm just a guitar player really
yo um robbie man thank you so much man
tanner
everybody go check out tanner and cobra
kai man it's an absolutely great series
that first season i haven't watched this
uh second season in full yet but the
first season
i thought it was one of like the best
incredible yeah it was one of the best
written stories
that i've ever seen like thank you it
was
amazing you guys were all great man so
uh keep up the great work man we'll stay
in touch
okay i'll take you out to get some
muffins or something all right see you
guys
peace
you